Professor Ben Polak:
So today we have a lot of
stuff to get through,
but it's all going to be fairly
formal.
We're not going to have time to
play a game today.
So it's going to be a day where
we have to learn some new ideas.
So the reason we need to go
through some new formal ideas
today is we've kind of exhausted
what we can do with the ideas
we've gathered so far.
So, just to bring us up to date
with where we are:
in the first half of the
semester--so before the
mid-term--we looked at
simultaneous move games.
And one way to think about
those simultaneous move games
were games where,
when I make my choice,
I don't know what you've done,
and, when you make your choice,
you don't know what I've done.
Since the mid-term we've been
looking at simple examples of
sequential move
games--sequential move games
under perfect information--in
which I typically do know what
you did when I get to make my
choice.
And you know I'm going to know
what you did when I get to make
my choice.
What I want to be able to do
moving forward is I want to be
able to look at strategic
situations that combine those
two settings.
I want to be able to analyze
games which involve both
sequential moves and
simultaneous move games.
In particular,
I want to see how we can extend
the technique we've been
focusing on for the last few
weeks which is backward
induction.
I want us to see how we can
extend the notion of backward
induction to cope with games
where some parts are sequential
and some parts are simultaneous.
So we're going to look at a lot
of examples and we're going to
introduce some new ideas,
and I'm going to try and walk
you through that today.
So that's our goal.
Let's start with an example.
So here's a very simple game in
which Player 1 moves first,
and has three choices.
Let's call them up,
middle, and down.
And then Player 2 moves,
and Player 2 has two choices
from each of these nodes,
and we'll call the choices
suggestively,
up and down--up and down.
And here we'll just call them
left and right.
The payoffs are as follows,
(4,0), (0,4),
(0,4), (4,0),
(1,2), (0,0).
So this is just a standard game
of perfect information,
much like all the games we've
seen since the mid-term.
In fact, it's a relatively easy
one.
So we know how to solve this
game.
We solve this game using what?
Using backward induction,
and that isn't so hard here.
We know that if Player 2 finds
herself up here,
she will choose 4 rather than
0;
if she finds herself here,
she'll choose 4 rather than 0;
and if she finds herself here,
she'll choose 2 rather than 1.
So Player 1 won't want to go up
here because he'll get 0,
and he won't want to go into
the middle because he'll get 0,
and he won't want to--but if he
goes down Player 1 will choose
left and Player 1 will get 1.
So Player 1 will choose down.
So backward induction predicts
that Player 1 chooses down and
Player 2 responds by choosing
left.
Just staring at this a second,
notice that the reason in this
game--taking a step back from
backward induction a second--the
reason Player 1 did not want to
choose either up or middle was
because that move was going to
be observed by Player 2,
and in either case Player 2 was
going to crush Player 1.
So if Player 1 went up,
Player 2 was playing this sort
of "strictly competitive game"
with Player 1 and Player 2 could
pick a choice that gave 2 4 and
1 0.
Conversely, if Player 1 chose
middle, Player 2 could crush
Player 1 by choosing up,
which gave, once again,
Player 2 4 and Player 1 0.
So there was a good reason here
to avoid going into the part of
the game following up or middle,
and the reason was 2 has a huge
second-mover advantage in those
parts of the game.
Is that clear to everybody?
So I now want to consider a
similar, but importantly
different game,
so I'm going to draw the game
again,
but before I draw it,
let me say what I'm going to
do.
So I want to introduce a new
idea, and the new idea is going
to be that Player 2 will not be
able to distinguish between up
or middle.
So let's just say it again.
So if Player 1 chooses down,
Player 2 will observe that,
just as we've done before in
our standard perfect-information
games,
but if Player 1 chooses either
up or middle,
I want to capture the idea that
Player 2 doesn't know which of
those two choices was made.
That's clearly going to change
the game a lot and the first
question is, how do we represent
that idea in a tree?
So let me try and show a good
way to represent that in a tree.
So the game has the same
structure to it.
Player 1 is again choosing
between up, middle,
or down.
And Player 2 once again is
choosing here,
up or down, up or down,
and here left or right.
And the payoffs haven't changed.
They're still (4,0),
(0,4), (4,0),
(0,4), (1,2) and (0,0).
So that's exactly the same as
you have in your notes already,
but now I want to adapt this
tree to show how we indicate
that Player 2 cannot
distinguish--cannot observe
whether 1 chose up or middle,
but can observe if Player 1 has
chosen down.
The way we do that very simply,
we draw a dotted line between
the two nodes of Player 2
between which 2 cannot
distinguish.
So this idea here,
what this dotted line indicates
is that these two nodes are set
in the same information set.
So our new idea here is the
idea of an information set.
The payoffs are meant be the
same on the left as on the
right.
So the idea here is that Player
2 cannot distinguish these two
nodes.
Player 2 knows that she's in
this information set:
she knows that Player 1 must
have chosen either up or middle,
she knows that Player 1 did not
choose down, but she doesn't
know whether she's really here
or here.
Now what happens in this game?
This game is a very different
game.
Why is it a different game?
Well let's try and apply that
loose intuition we talked about
before.
We said previously,
in the old game,
that if Player 1 chose up,
2 knew that Player 1 had chosen
up,
and observed that by choosing
down Player 2 could crush 1.
And if Player 1 chose middle,
Player 2 could observe that
Player 1 had chosen middle and
this time by choosing up could
crush 1.
The problem is that now in this
new game Player 2 doesn't know
whether she's here,
in which case she would want to
choose down, or here,
in which case she'd want to
choose up.
So Player 2's choice is not so
obvious anymore.
That simple backward induction
argument has disappeared.
Moreover, Player 1 knows that
Player 2 will not be able to
observe between up or middle,
so it isn't necessarily the
case that Player 1 will want to
choose down anymore.
It's still true that if Player
1 did choose down that Player 2
would be able to observe that
and will choose left,
so that part of the argument's
the same.
What do we think is going to
happen here?
Well we don't know,
but let me give a suggestion
what might happen here.
Player 1 might say,
hey I could randomize between
up and middle.
I could choose half the time up
and half the time middle.
If I choose half the time up
and half the time middle,
Player 2 isn't going to
know--in general--isn't going to
know what I've done.
It isn't quite clear what
Player 2's going to do and since
I'm randomizing between up or
middle whatever Player 2's going
to do,
I'm going to get half the time
4 and half the time 0 for an
expected value of 2.
So to say it again,
so Player 1 might decide in
this game to randomize
fifty-fifty between up and
middle,
knowing that half the time
therefore he will get 4 and half
the time he'll get 0 for an
expected value of 2,
which notice is better than he
got by choosing down.
So this change in this game,
change in the information in
this game, not only led to a
different game but led to a very
different outcome.
So here 1 might,
for example,
might randomize between up and
middle, and over here we know
exactly what 1 does,
1 chooses down.
So we get very different
outcomes because of this change
in information in the game,
and the theme of today is that
information is going to matter.
The way we're going to model
information is by thinking about
these information sets.
And as we go through today,
I want to start giving you some
formal definitions.
So this is the idea,
now let's look at the formal
definition.
There's going to be a lot of
writing today,
so I hope you brought a notepad
with some room on it.
So the first formal definition
of the day comes off that last
example.
The formal definition is the
idea that I want to capture:
I want to capture the idea that
players down the tree may not
know exactly what was done up
the tree.
And the formal definition is
going to go through the idea of
an information set.
So an information set of Player
i--in this case involves Player
2 but more generally of Player
i--is a collection--or a set if
you like--is a collection of
Player i's nodes between
which--I guess it can be more
than two--so let's say
among which i cannot
distinguish.
Now it's going to turn out
that, by clever use of
information sets,
we're going to be able to use
our technology,
our technology of drawing
trees, to capture all sorts of
interesting and increasingly
complicated information
settings.
In this particular game,
it's the case that Player 1
knew that Player 2 was not going
to be able to distinguish
between up or middle in this
tree,
and Player 1 knew that Player 2
would be able to distinguish in
the left hand tree.
We can even use information
sets in a more elaborate tree to
capture the idea that Player 1
may not know what Player 2's
going to know.
But I won't do that now:
I'll leave that later,
and you'll see some examples of
that on the homework.
So we have our formal
definition.
This is going to be the first
of our big tools of the day,
but let me just put down a few
things that we have to be
careful about:
a couple of rules.
So these information sets have
to obey certain rules and
certain things are not allowed.
So in particular the following
is not allowed.
Here's a tree in which Player 1
moves first and Player 2 does
not observe Player 1's move.
So these two nodes are Player
2's nodes.
They're in the same information
set, which means Player 2 is not
meant to be able to distinguish
between these two nodes.
And suppose however the tree
looked like this.
Okay, so I claim that this is
crazy.
We couldn't allow this.
It wouldn't make any sense to
allow this.
Can anyone see why?
Why is this not really a
sensible tree?
Everyone see that?
Why is that not a sensible tree?
Student: If Player 2
knows that he has three choices
then he'll know he's at the top
node.
Professor Ben Polak:
Exactly, in this tree you
haven't got the payoffs in,
but if Player 2 observes that
she has three choices,
she knows she must be at the
top node.
If she observes she has two
choices she must be at the
bottom node.
So in this tree,
it was supposed to be the case
that 2 didn't know whether she
was here or here,
but merely by observing how
many choices she has,
she could infer whether she was
at the top node or the bottom
node.
So that can't make any sense.
So this is not allowed,
so we'll put a red cross
through that one.
Now the second thing that's not
allowed is a little bit more
subtle, and actually is an
interesting thing.
This is just kind of
bookkeeping, but the second
thing is more interesting.
So let's have a look at it.
Here's a more interesting tree.
Player 1 moves first.
Player 2 observes that move,
and Player 2 moves second.
And then at the bottom of this
Player 1 may have another chance
to move again.
So again I haven't put payoffs
in here.
Player 1 moves first;
Player 2 moves second;
and, if Player 2 chooses down
here or up there,
then Player 1 gets to move
again.
Now I claim again that this is
not a sensible tree.
It's not a sensible arrangement
of information sets.
Can anyone see why this isn't
sensible?
Why is this not sensible?
Steven?
Student: Player 1 knows
what node he's at based on the
first choice that he made.
Professor Ben Polak:
Exactly, so to get to the upper
node here for Player 1,
Player 1 must have chosen up
before, and to get to the lower
node here, Player 1 must have
played down before.
So provided that Player 1
remembers his or her own move,
she knows where she is.
Is that right?
So provided that Player 1 can
recall what she herself did
earlier on in the tree she
should be able to distinguish
these things.
So we're going to rule this
out, but I just want to make a
remark here.
There's an assumption in ruling
it out and the assumption is
we're assuming perfect recall or
perfect memory.
And people don't always--in the
real world, players don't always
have perfect recall.
There are two reasons--and
we're always going to assume
this, but let me just make a
remark.
There are two reasons why
people might not have perfect
recall.
One reason is,
like me, they're getting old.
They simply can't remember what
they did yesterday.
So while I'm driving home I
know roughly how many traffic
lights I have to go through
before I turn right,
but I sometimes forget which
traffic light I'm at and I turn
right too early or too late.
That doesn't happen to you
guys, but it happens to me as
I'm getting a bit senile,
so old age would rule out
perfect recall.
A more important example,
perhaps, is if players of games
are themselves institutions.
It's sometimes useful,
and we've often talked about it
in this class,
to imagine a player of a game
being a firm or a country,
or some kind of institution in
which the actual decisions may
be being taken by different
actual people within the firm,
institution, or country.
This assumption of perfect
recall is saying that the
players within the institution
knew what the other players
within that same institution
were doing.
If we're modeling General
Motors as one player,
this assumption is assuming
that the chief financial officer
and the chief executive officer
at GM are observing each other's
actions: are on the same page.
The left hand knows what the
right hand's doing.
We are typically going to
assume that, but just to make
the point: it is an assumption,
and it's quite interesting to
see what happens if you relax
it.
So with that in mind,
we can move to our next
definition.
and this is something I've
referred to early on in the
class, but I want to be formal
now.
Now we can be formal.
We've talked earlier on in this
class about the idea of perfect
information.
So, for example,
when we talked about Zermelo's
theorem, we talked about games
of perfect information.
We said informally what this
was--a game of perfect
information is a game where each
player in the game can observe
all previous moves.
That was our informal
definition, but we can now give
a formal definition very simply.
Perfect information is a
setting where all information
sets in the tree--games of
perfect information are games
where all information sets in
the tree--contain just one node.
I want to be clear here.
What we're saying here is,
if we have a tree in which
every information set is a
singleton,
we basically don't have to
bother with any dotted lines:
that's a game of perfect
information.
And that shouldn't be a
surprise to anybody here because
that's exactly how we drew trees
since the mid-term.
Is that right?
Of course, the novelty is we're
now going to be allowed to look
at games of imperfect
information.
The reason we're doing this is
because it will be
interesting--as in the example
we've just seen--to think about
games where information is not
perfect.
So what is the definition of
imperfect information?
Imperfect information's formal
definition is "not perfect
information."
We've defined what perfect
information is.
Imperfect information is the
rest.
In the real world there's a lot
of games that turn out to have
imperfect information.
There's lots of strategic
situations where I'm going to be
able to observe some things that
you've done,
but other things,
I won't know quite what you've
done.
Okay, let's go straight to an
example.
So I don't think we really need
to keep that definition very
focal, so let's get rid of that
board.
Let's do an example.
We'll be doing many examples
today.
So this example is going to be
a tree in which Player 1 moves
first.
Player 2 cannot observe this
move;
and sometimes rather than
labeling both of these nodes
with a 2, I'll just put a 2 on
the information set,
just to indicate that both of
these nodes belong to Player 2.
So Player 2 moves second.
And we'll call Player 1's move
up or down;
and we'll call Player 2's move
left or right,
kind of suggestively.
So what's the information set
here?
The information set is
indicating the fact that Player
2 cannot observe whether Player
1 moved up or down.
Player 2 cannot observe whether
Player 1 chose up or down.
Now, why does that matter?
I haven't put the payoffs in
yet but I will in a second.
It matters because had this
game been a game of perfect
information, had this
information set--had there been
two information sets here,
this dotted line not been there
--, then Player 2 could have
chosen separately whether to
choose left or right at this
node,
or left and left or right at
this node.
But since Player 2 doesn't know
whether she's at the upper node
or the lower node--she doesn't
know whether Player 1 chose up
or down--she really only has one
choice to make here.
She's either choosing left at
both nodes or she's choosing
right at both nodes.
And just to pull it back to our
first example in the class,
we saw the same feature there.
When we moved from a game of
perfect information to a game of
imperfect information we reduced
the choices available for Player
2.
Here Player 2 could choose
separately up or down,
at these two different nodes.
But here Player 2 only makes
one choice that has to apply to
both nodes because Player 2
cannot distinguish those two
nodes.
So let's have a look and see,
once we put some payoffs on,
what it does in this particular
game.
So here's some payoffs:
(2,2), (-1,3),
(3, -1) and (0,0).
So once again Player 2 cannot
separately choose at the upper
node or the lower node,
she's either choosing left or
she's choosing right.
But it turns out that this game
is a little easier than the game
we started with.
Why is it easier than the game
we started with?
It's easier than the game that
we started with because,
from Player 2's point of view,
whether she thinks she's up
here or whether she thinks she's
down here, she has the same best
choice in either case.
If she thinks she's at the
upper node then by choosing left
she'll get 2 and right she'll
get 3, so right seems better.
If she thinks she's at the
lower node then choosing left
gets -1 and right gets 0,
so once again right is better.
So in fact, in this particular
game, regardless of whether
Player 2 thinks that Player 1
chose up,
and hence she's at the upper
node, or whether Player 2 thinks
that Player 1 chose down,
and hence she's at the lower
node, Player 2 is going to make
the same choice in this game,
namely right.
So notice that this particular
game actually solves out rather
like backward induction.
Even though Player 2's choice
is a little bit more
complicated--she doesn't know
where she is--it's actually
clear what Player 2 will do at
this information set.
Now if we push this forward a
little bit harder,
we can see why.
Player 1 in this game has two
strategies up or down.
And Player 2 has two
strategies, she either chooses
left or right.
Notice that she only has two
strategies because she has to
choose the same thing at these
two nodes, she doesn't know
where she is.
Okay, so let's draw up the
matrix for this game and see if
it looks familiar.
So Player 1 is choosing between
up or down.
And Player 2 is choosing
between left or right.
And the payoffs are as follows:
(up, left) is (2,2);
(up, right) is (-1,3);
(down, left) is (3,-1);
and (down, right) is (0,0).
So what game is this?
It wasn't meant to be a trick
question.
Somebody waved their arm in the
air.
What game is this?
Student: Prisoners'
Dilemma.
Professor Ben Polak:
This is Prisoners' Dilemma.
This is an old friend of ours.
This is Prisoner's Dilemma,
a game we saw the very first
day.
But notice what have we seen
here?
This is Prisoner's Dilemma that
we've seen many,
many times, that's almost
unbearably familiar to most of
you.
Now here's Prisoner's Dilemma
as represented the way in which
we talked about games before the
mid-term.
But here is the same game.
This is also Prisoner's
Dilemma, but now I've drawn it
in a tree.
Here I drew it in a matrix,
and here I drew it in a tree.
Now that we have information
sets we can represent all the
games that we've studied before
the mid-term.
All the games that were
simultaneous move games we can
study using trees by building
information sets.
What's the key observation here?
It doesn't really matter
whether Player 1 moves first or
Player 2 moves first.
It doesn't really matter what's
happening temporally in this
game.
What matters is information.
When Player 1 makes her move
she doesn't know what Player 2's
going to do.
She doesn't know what 2 is
doing.
And when Player 2 makes her
move she doesn't know what 1 is
doing: and that's a simultaneous
move game, even if time is
passing.
The key is information,
not time.
Now, on the way here I snuck
something in and I should just
tell you what I snuck in.
I snuck in what a strategy is.
I went from a tree,
or an extensive form game,
to a normal form game,
and we've already done that a
couple of times before in the
class.
We did it with the entry game,
for example,
about a week ago.
But there all we did was we
defined what a strategy was in a
game of perfect information.
And just to remind you,
a strategy in a game of perfect
information is a complete plan
of action.
It tells the player in question
what they should do at each of
their nodes.
But now we have to be a bit
more careful.
We can't have a strategy--once
we move to imperfect
information--we can't have a
strategy tell you what to do at
each of your nodes,
because you yourself can't
distinguish between those nodes.
So we need to adapt our
definition of a strategy to make
it appropriate for these more
complicated games.
So let's just adapt it in the
obvious way.
Definition, I'll just define
pure strategies for now.
A pure strategy of Player i is
a complete plan of action--so
this is the same as before.
But what does it mean to be a
complete plan of action?
It can't tell me what to do at
every single node.
That can't be the right
definition because I can't
distinguish nodes.
So all that it can be doing is
telling me what to do at each
information set.
So it specifies what Player i
should do--should perhaps is the
wrong word, let's just say
will do at each of i's
information sets.
So if you go back about a week
you'll see almost exactly the
same definition of a strategy,
but the previous definition
told i what to do at each node
and this one just tells i what
to do at each information set.
What I'm doing is tidying up
the previous definition so we
can apply it to the more
interesting games we're going to
look at from now on.
So now we have the definition
of a strategy,
we can carry on the idea we've
just seen here.
So what's the idea here?
Any game you give me in the
form of a tree,
I can rewrite the game in the
form of a matrix.
So let's see some other
examples of that idea.
A lot of new ideas today,
but some of them are just
tidying up and kind of
bookkeeping, and some of them
are more interesting.
So let's start with a tree.
Let's make it a slightly more
interesting tree than the one
we've seen before.
Actually that's too
interesting, let's go a little
bit slower.
Let's have Player 1 have two
choices, and Player 2 have three
choices.
So here's a simple tree,
and let's put some payoffs in,
but let me just put some
letters in for payoffs rather
than put in numbers.
So we'll call these actions up
and down.
And we'll call this action
left, middle,
and right;
and left, middle, and right.
And we'll call the payoffs
(A1,A2), (B1,B2),
(C1,C2), (D1,D2),
(E1,E2), and (F1,F2),
so just to keep track of it.
I want to show you how we take
this tree and turn it into a
matrix.
So how do we turn it into a
matrix?
Well we look and say how many
strategies has Player 1 got and
how many strategies has Player 2
got?
So Player 1 here just has two
strategies, up or down.
And Player 2 has three
strategies, either left,
middle or right.
Again they can't choose
separately at these two nodes,
so they really just have three
choices: left,
middle, or right.
Leave a space here in your
notebook, leave a space to the
right here, and let's draw the
matrix for this tree down here.
So here's my matrix.
Player 2 is choosing left,
middle, or right and Player 1
is choosing up or down.
The payoffs go in the obvious
way.
So (A1,A2), (B1,B2),
(C1,C2), (D1,D2),
(E1,E2), and (F1,F2).
So everyone understand that was
just a simple exercise to show
we can go from an extensive
form, a tree,
to the normal form,
a matrix?
That was easy right.
However, there's an interesting
thing here.
It isn't obvious that,
if I just gave you the matrix,
it isn't obvious that this is
the tree from which it came.
Let me draw another tree that I
claim corresponds to that same
matrix.
Here's another tree.
So this other tree instead of
having Player 1 move first,
it's going to have Player 2
move first.
Player 2 better have three
choices and we better call them
left, middle,
and right.
And it better be the case that
Player 1 is in one big
information set and Player 1
only has two choices,
which we'll call up and down
because that's what this matrix
is telling us.
It's telling us Player 2 had
three choices and Player 1 had
two choices.
So that's true in the matrix
I've drawn.
And let's be a little bit
careful where the payoffs are.
So (left, up),
that's easy:
that's going to be (A1,A2).
(Left, down) is going to be
(D1,D2).
(Middle, up) is going to be
(B1,B2).
(Middle, down) is going to be
(E1,E2).
(Right, up) is going to be
(C1,C2) and (right,down) is
going to be (F1,F2).
So I have to be a little bit
careful where I put in the
payoffs, but I think that's
right what I just did.
Notice that what I did here:
I started from this tree.
It was an easy operation to
construct the matrix,
so easy that it was kind of
boring,
and it's not that hard to see
that I can go the other way and
construct this other tree from
the matrix.
This is also a tree in which
Player 2 has three strategies
and Player 1,
this is all Player 1,
has two strategies.
So what, what have we learned
from this?
Well let's look at this more
carefully.
This tree is a tree in which
Player 1 moved first and Player
2 didn't observe Player 1's
choice.
Is that right?
This is a tree in which Player
2 moved first and Player 1
didn't observe 2's choice.
What are we noticing here?
They're really the same game.
There's no difference between
these two games.
They're really the same game.
It doesn't matter whether it's
Player 1 moving first and Player
2 who's unable to observe 1's
choice,
or whether it's Player 2 who is
moving first and Player 1 who is
unable to observe 2's choice.
All that matters is that
neither player could observe the
other person's choice before
they got to move,
they both correspond to exactly
the same game.
So what's the message here?
The message is something we've
talked about before in the
class, but I'm trying to be a
bit more formal about it.
The message is that what
matters is information,
not time.
Clearly, time isn't an
irrelevant thing.
I couldn't know something that
hasn't happened yet,
so time is going to have
effects in information,
but ultimately what matters is
information.
What do I know and when did I
know it?
So the key idea that we're
trying to capture with these
information sets,
just to repeat,
is what did the player know and
when did they know it,
that famous expression from the
Watergate Trials.
Okay, let's look at a more
interesting example,
and see if we can actually talk
about what's going to happen in
these games.
So by the end of today I want
to have enough machinery so we
can actually start analyzing
these games and predicting
what's going to happen.
So as we go on we'll get more
complicated, so let's get a
little bit more complicated now.
Once again, here's a game in
which Player 1 is going to have
two choices and we'll call those
choices Up or Down.
It's getting to be a familiar
theme.
Once again, Player 2 is going
to move next and now,
this time, just to keep things
simple,
we'll have Player 2 just have
two choices left or right,
or left or right.
But now I want to make things
more interesting,
let's have Player 1 move again.
So if Up, right happens then
Player 1 gets to move again,
in which case Player 1 is going
to choose up or down.
I'll use a [little]
u and a [little]
d to distinguish it from the
ones further to the left of the
tree.
So this is a very simple tree,
Player 1 moves first.
Player 2 moves second--I forgot
to put a 2 in here.
And then if (Up,
right) has occurred then Player
1 gets to move again.
Let's put some payoffs in.
So let's have this be (4,2),
(0,0), (1,4),
(0,0) again and (2,4).
Let's just carry on analyzing
this game using exactly the
methods we've been talking about
in the class today so far.
So the first thing I'm going to
do is I want to turn this into a
matrix.
The first thing to do on that
route is to try and figure out
how many strategies does Player
1 have, and how many strategies
does Player 2 have.
Before we even do that let's
try and figure out how many
information sets they have.
So I claim that Player 2 just
has the one information set,
is that right?
But Player 1 has two
information sets.
This information set at the
beginning of the game and then
potentially this second
information further down the
tree.
A strategy must tell you--a
strategy must tell the player
what to do at each of their
information sets.
So the strategies for Player 1
are what?
Well one strategy is Up and
then up again,
another strategy is Up and then
right,
another strategy is Down and
then up, and a fourth strategy
is Down and then right.
Notice something which we've
seen already in this class
before: there's a little bit of
a redundancy here.
These two Down strategies force
the game into a part of the tree
where this node will not arise.
To put it less grandly,
if Player 1 chooses Down,
she knows that she won't have
to make a choice of up or down
later on.
Yes.
Sorry--thank you.
Let me start again since that
was the wrong notation.
So Player 1's choices are Up
and then up;
Up and then down;
Down and then up;
and Down and then down.
Thanks Jake, sorry.
Now, why are there four
strategies?
It's a bit of a surprise
perhaps because if Player 1
chooses Down then she knows she
will never have to make a choice
at her second information set.
Nevertheless,
when we write down a strategy
we have to write down an
instruction for every single
information set.
So we include both of those
strategies.
Strategies for Player 2 here
are a little bit easier.
Strategies for Player 2 are
just left or right.
With that in mind,
let's draw up the matrix.
So Player 1 here has four
strategies and they are (Up,
up), (Up, down),
(Down, up), and (Down,
down).
Player 2 has two strategies,
and they are left or right.
Everyone okay so far?
We're just basically
transferring things across,
and then we have to transfer
the payoffs across so (Up,
up) followed by left is going
to be (4,2).
(Up, up) followed by right is
going to be (0,0).
So Up, right, up is (0,0).
((Up, down),
left) is the same as Up,
left, down so it's going to be
(4,2).
((Up, down),
right) is going to be Up,
right, down so it's going to be
(1,4).
((Down, up),
left) is the same as saying
Down, left so it's going to be
(0,0).
((Down, up),
right) is going to be (2,4).
((Down, down),
left) is once again going to be
(0,0) and ((Down,
down), right) is once again
going to be (2,4).
Does everyone see how I got the
payoffs?
I just used those strategies to
tell me which way I'm going
through the tree.
If I combine them,
it gives me an entire path and
gets me to an end node.
You can see this redundancy we
talked about.
We pointed out that these
things are kind of the same
thing, and you can see in the
matrix that the bottom four
squares of the matrix have
repetition.
This row is the same as that
row.
Everyone happy with that?
Okay, we have a matrix.
Let's analyze it by finding the
Nash equilibria in this game.
So to find the Nash equilibria
in this game,
we're going to find best
responses.
So let's just start by asking
what is the best response to
left?
So if Player 2 chooses left,
Player 1's best response is
either (Up, up) or (Up,
down).
If Player 2 chooses right then
Player 1's best response is
either (Down,
up) or (Down,
down).
Everyone okay so far?
If Player 1 chooses (Up,
up) then Player 2 is going to
choose left.
If Player 1 chooses (Up,
down) then Player 2's best
response is to choose right.
If Player 1 chooses (Down,
up) then Player 2's best
response is to choose right.
And if Player 1 chooses (Down,
down) then Player 2's best
response is to choose right.
So this is kind of slow and I
just want to be careful.
I'm going slow for a reason.
We're going to gradually get
harder, and I want to be a
little bit careful.
I can see people are looking a
little sleepy around the room.
I know it's kind of lunchtime.
If you see your neighbor
getting sleepy give them a good
sharp elbow because I think this
isn't a good time to fall
asleep.
Sometimes I'm worried you're
going to miss something,
and it's only going to get
harder and you're going to miss
things.
Alright, so what are the Nash
equilibria in this game?
We know how to do that.
The Nash equilibria must be
(Up, up) followed by left.
Make sure I get them all.
(Down, up) followed by right;
and (Down, down) followed by
right.
I want these three Nash
equilibria.
Okay, so that wasn't such a big
deal.
I've got three equilibria in
this game.
And if I'd simply given you
this game in the first half of
the semester,
I hadn't shown you the
tree--you've never seen this
tree--I just gave you this game
and said find the Nash
equilibria in this game,
and that had been a question on
the mid-term,
we'd have stopped here.
We'd have said:
okay, I found these Nash
equilibria.
Maybe you'd have gone on and
found mixed ones I don't know
but essentially we'd be done at
this point.
Let's say again.
If we'd started as we would
have done before the mid-term
with me giving you a payoff
matrix and asking you to find
the Nash equilibria,
then at this point we'd be done.
We'd have found the three Nash
equilibria, at least the three
pure-strategy Nash equilibria.
The problem is if we go back to
the tree, to the dynamic
game--the game that has some
action going on in it--and
actually look at this game,
it's not clear that all of
these Nash equilibria are really
equally plausible.
Can anyone see what might be a
bit implausible about some of
these Nash equilibria?
What's implausible about them?
Any taker on this?
Well, let's look at this game
again.
This game is a little bit
complicated.
It's not clear what one should
do here perhaps,
and perhaps it's not clear what
Player 2 should do here,
because after all,
Player 2 doesn't know where he
is and he doesn't know whether
Player 1,
if Player 1 gets to move again
is going to choose up or down
but: what's the but?
Can we get a mike on Patrick?
Student: So if you look
at it backwards,
you can cross out Player 1's
second choice.
He's always going to choose
down so that's (1,4) at that
node.
So then you know Player 2 is
always going to choose right
because his payoff is always 4.
So then Player 1's not going to
have--I mean Player 1 knows
which to choose then.
He's going to choose down.
Professor Ben Polak:
Good.
So let's just walk through what
Patrick just said.
That's very good.
So if we just analyze this game
the way we've been taught to
analyze trees,
essentially using backward
induction,
we first of all observe that if
Player 1 gets to move again here
she'll know where she is,
and she'll know she's choosing
between 1 and 0.
She's going to choose down.
Is that right?
But knowing this,
Player 2, even though Player 2
doesn't know where he is,
Player 2 actually has a pretty
easy choice to make.
He knows that if he chooses
left, he either gets 2 or 0,
but if he chooses right he gets
4.
4 is bigger than 2.
4 is bigger than 0.
So Player 2 is actually going
to choose right.
And given that,
given that Player 2 is going to
choose right,
Player 1 is essentially
choosing between 1,
if she chooses up,
which would be followed by
right and down;
and 2, which is what happened
if she chooses down followed by
right.
So this game we can essentially
analyze through backward
induction.
It's not quite backward
induction because we had to add
in this little piece about 2 not
knowing where she was,
but it turned out,
no matter where she was,
she had a dominant strategy,
she had a better strategy once
she figures out that Player 1 is
going to choose down.
Is that right?
If we go back and look at these
Nash equilibria,
the prediction that we just
got, which is what?
Down for Player 1,
right for Player 2 and then
down again for Player 1.
That strategy is this one.
So one of these Nash equilibria
corresponds to our sensible
analysis of this tree,
but the other two do not.
These two Nash equilibria are
inconsistent with backward
induction.
They're perfectly good Nash
equilibria, if we'd given you
this matrix at the mid-term
you'd have thought that it's
just fine.
But it turns out both of these
Nash equilibria involve Player 1
choosing a strategy up,
that we know that Player 1 is
not going to do if reached.
And one of these Nash
equilibria involves Player 2
choosing a strategy left,
that, in fact,
she's only choosing because she
thinks Player 1 is going to
choose up,
which, in fact,
we just argued Player 1 is not
going to do.
The people at the back,
there's a little bit too much
volume bouncing off the wall
there, so just keep it down in
the balcony.
Thank you.
So these two Nash equilibria,
they're perfectly good Nash
equilibria to the game,
but they don't make any sense.
They're completely inconsistent
with the way we've learned to
talk about games.
Now we've seen this before.
We saw it in the entry game.
This is a much more
complicated, much more
interesting example,
but we saw in the entry game
when there was one entrant
entering into a market,
that in that game there were
actually two Nash equilibria and
one of them we argued was
incredible.
Here it's a bit more
complicated, but nevertheless,
these two equilibria seem like
bogus equilibria or phony
equilibria,
or equilibria we wouldn't
really believe in.
The reason we don't believe in
them is that they don't
correspond to backward induction
and our common sense intuition
is about backward induction.
So we need some new notion,
the aim of the class has been
what?
We want to be able to model
games that have both sequential
moves and simultaneous moves,
and we want to be able to look
at the games and use our
techniques from both halves of
the class.
We want to be able to use the
idea of Nash equilibrium from
the first half of the class,
and we want to be able to use
the idea of backward induction
from the second half of the
class.
But what we're learning here is
that Nash equilibrium,
if we just take the notion of
Nash equilibrium and plunk it
down on these sequential move
games,
it will produce equilibria that
don't make any sense.
So we need a more refined
notion of equilibrium,
a better notion of equilibrium
than just Nash equilibrium to
deal with these settings where
we have both simultaneity and
sequential moves.
We have both some perfect
information and some imperfect
information.
That was one example.
Let me give you a second
example if that example wasn't
yet convincing.
Let me leave that example up.
So far we've seen that Nash
equilibrium gets us into trouble
in these games and we've seen it
got us into trouble because it
basically conflicted with our
backward induction intuitions.
Now I'm going to show you a
different game and we're going
to see again that Nash
equilibria is going to get us
into trouble.
This is a going to be a
three-player game.
We will get more complicated as
we go along.
So another example,
this time with three players.
So as the examples get harder I
need you to be more alert to see
if you can follow them.
So this is a more complicated
tree.
Here's a tree in which Player 1
moves first and chooses between
A or B and if Player 1 chooses A
the game is over,
she gets 1, and the other two
players get nothing.
If she chooses B then Players 2
and 3 get to play a little game
down here in which 2 moves first
in this little sub-game and 3
moves second,
and the payoffs in this
sub-game are as follows.
Again, using Player 1's payoff
first.
So there's (0,1,
1), (0,0, 2),
(0,0, -1) and (2,1,
0).
So this is quite a complicated
game, it's got three players for
a start, so it's going to be a
little bit hard to draw it up in
a matrix,
but nevertheless,
let me try and do that.
So I claim that we can model
this game as follows.
It's a game in which Player 1
is choosing which matrix,
let's call this Matrix A and
Matrix B.
Player 1 is choosing the
matrix, Player 2 is choosing,
let's call them up and down:
Player 2 is choosing up or
down.
And Player 3 is choosing left
or right.
Notice in this game Players 2
and 3 actually can observe the
choice of A or B to start with.
So let's try and put in the
payoffs in the correct places.
It's not always easy to do,
but let's try.
So A is easy,
if Player 1 chooses A,
then the payoffs in this matrix
are somewhat trivial.
Because if Player 1 chooses A,
whatever anyone else does the
payoff is 1,0,
0.
Somewhat uninteresting matrix
over there.
But if Player 1 chooses B then
life gets more interesting.
Then if Player 2 chooses up and
Player 3 chooses left,
we end up here so that's
(0,1,1).
If Player 2 chooses--this is 2
and this is 3--if Player 2
chooses up and Player 3 chooses
right then we're at (0,0,2),
so this is (0,0,2) going in
here.
If Player 2 chooses down and
Player 3 chooses left then we're
at (0,0,-1).
Everyone okay with that?
If Player 3 chooses down then
we're down here which is (2,1,
0).
Okay so here's a little game.
Player 1 is choosing the
matrix, Player 2 is choosing the
row in the matrix,
albeit trivially on the left
hand side and Player 3 is
choosing the column in the
matrix,
again, albeit trivially on the
left hand side.
We don't really care about this
picture very much.
Okay, so now what?
Well, once again we could look
for Nash equilibria in this
game.
It turns out there are lots of
Nash equilibria in this game.
Let me just show you one Nash
equilibrium and then we'll talk
about it.
So I claim that there are lots
of Nash equilibria,
and one of them is the Nash
equilibrium (A,
up, left).
So let's just see where that is
in the tree first of all.
So Player 1 chose A,
Player 2 chose up and left,
but it followed A so we end up
here, we end up at (1,0,
0).
So (A, up, left) is this box in
the tree.
Now, let's just check that that
actually is a Nash equilibrium.
So we all know how to do this
from the first half of the
class.
So to check that that's a Nash
equilibrium we better check that
no individual player can do
better by deviating.
So let's start with Player 1.
If Player 1 deviates holding
Player 2 and 3 fixed,
then Player 1 will be switching
the matrix from Matrix A to
Matrix B.
Is that correct?
So we'll move from this box in
the left hand matrix to the
equivalent box in the right hand
matrix.
Player 1's payoff will go from
1 to 0, so Player 1 doesn't want
to deviate.
Everyone happy with that?
Player 1 doesn't want to
deviate here.
How about Player 2?
If Player 2 deviates,
holding Players 1 and 3 fixed,
then Player 1 is going to
switch rows in this matrix,
so we'll move from this box to
this box.
Player 2 was making 0 before.
She's still making 0,
so she has no incentive to
deviate.
And the same argument applies
for Player 3 because she will be
choosing the column holding the
row in the matrix fixed,
so once again she gets 0 in
either case.
So everyone happy with that?
So that actually is a Nash
equilibria, and again,
if this had been on the
mid-term I could have set this
up,
I could have given you these
matrices or the story behind
them, and you'd have found--I
could have asked you whether
this was a Nash equilibrium and
the answer would have been yes.
But I claim that once again
this is just not a believable
Nash equilibrium.
It is a Nash equilibrium,
formally it's a Nash
equilibrium, but it's not a
plausible prediction for how
this game is going to be played.
Why is it not a plausible
prediction for how this game's
going to played?
Anyone see?
Stare at the tree a bit.
So in the information here,
the pre-mid-term information,
it's fine.
But knowing about the actual
structure of this game I claim
this makes no sense at all.
Why does it make no sense?
Well, notice that if Player 1
were to switch her action from
the prescribed action A to
action B, then we'd be here.
Notice that the tree from here
on in looks like a little game,
is that right?
The tree from here on looks
like a little game.
So this thing here,
let's put it in green,
is a little game within the
game.
It's a sub-game.
This sub-game really only
involves two players.
The two players that it
involves are Player 2 and Player
3.
Player 1 is done,
Player 1 has put us into this
game, but now this little
sub-game, it's a little sub-game
involving just Player 2 and
Player 3.
So we can analyze this little
sub-game.
If we analyze this little
sub-game, what will it give us?
What will we find?
So let's look at this sub-game.
So look at the green sub-game,
the game that would have
happened had Player 1 chosen B.
This is a sub-game involving
just Players 2 and 3.
So why don't I just forget
Player 1.
We know--I mean Player 1 is
part of the game,
he's getting payoffs,
but Player 1 has made their
move, they're not really
involved any more.
So let's just look at this game
as a game involving Players 2
and 3, and let's look at the
matrix for Players 2 and 3.
So it actually corresponds to
the matrix above,
it's a matrix in which Player 2
is choosing up and down.
There it is up and down and
simultaneously Player 3 is
choosing left or right.
There it is left or right at
this information set and the
payoffs are (1,1),
(0,2), (0, -1) and (1,0).
So this is, I claim,
a representation of this little
green game.
Perhaps we should put this in
green as well.
This thing corresponds to that
thing.
Everyone okay with that?
So if Player 1 had chosen B
rather than A,
then we'd be involved in a
little game, a game within a
game, or a sub-game involving
just Players 2 or 3.
And we can analyze that game.
That's a straightforward game.
Here it is.
And what would we do with that
game?
We'd look for the Nash
equilibria in that game.
So let's look for the Nash
equilibrium of this game.
So what do we notice about this
game?
So if Player 3 chooses left
then Player 2 would rather
choose up.
If Player 3 chooses right then
Player 2 should choose down.
If Player 2 chooses up then
Player 3 would rather choose
right, because 2 is bigger than
1.
And if Player 2 were to choose
down than Player 3 would choose
right again, because 0 is bigger
than -1.
So in fact, in this little
sub-game, actually,
Player 3 has a dominant
strategy.
If it turned out that we got
involved in this little
sub-game, Player 3 has a
dominant strategy which is to
play right,
and moreover,
this sub-game has just one Nash
equilibrium.
If I'd given you this sub-game
on its own, it's clear that the
Nash equilibrium of this
sub-game--this game within a
game--is (down,
right).
So what's that telling us?
It's telling us if Player 2 and
3 ever get called upon to play
in this game--and that only
happens when Player 1 chooses
B--if Player 2 and 3 ever get
called upon to play in this
game,
we know from when we were young
or at least from before the
mid-term, we know that they're
going to play Nash equilibrium
in that sub-game.
And the Nash equilibrium in the
sub-game is going to have Player
3 choosing right and Player 2
choosing down.
But the equilibrium we talked
about, this equilibrium we
argued before about,
(A, U, L)--the equilibrium we
talked about before,
(A, U, L), doesn't involve
Player 2 choosing down.
In fact she chose up.
And it doesn't involve Player 3
choosing right.
In fact she chose left.
So let's sum up.
We found an equilibrium of this
game, this equilibrium of this
game was (A, U,
L) but I claim this is not a
plausible equilibrium.
It's not a plausible
equilibrium because it predicts
that if we actually were to play
the game within the game,
we wouldn't play equilibrium.
Let me say it again,
in the whole game (A,
U, L) is an equilibrium.
But I claim it's a silly
equilibrium because it involves
the prediction that,
if in fact we ever got into the
game within the game,
we would no longer play
equilibrium,
and that doesn't seem right.
If we're going to believe in
equilibrium, we should be
consistent and believe in
equilibrium throughout.
So this brings us to a new idea
and the new idea is going to
have two parts to it.
The first part is kind of on
the board already.
It's something we talked about
informally.
It's the notion of a sub-game.
What's a sub-game?
It's a game within a game.
I've been using that informally
but we need to start thinking
about, more formally,
what it means.
So I talked about it informally.
I said that green object is the
game that would be played were
Player 1 to choose B.
We talked about other sub-games
in this class.
We talked about the sub-game
that would happen in the entry
game if one of those rival pizza
companies moved in,
in the Miami market or
something, the game within a
game.
When we talked about the Tour
de France we talked about there
being a game within a game that
is about when you break away.
But now I want to be formal
about this notion of a game
within a game and introduce some
nomenclature.
So the formal definition is
this.
A sub-game is a part of a game,
informally that looks like a
game within the tree,
and it has three properties.
It satisfies the following
three properties.
So one since it looks a game
itself the sub-game must start
from a particular point.
So it starts--the sub-game must
start--it starts from a single
node.
Let's just look at the example.
In the example we just looked
at, the sub-game started from
this node here.
Second, it comprises all
successors to that node.
So in our example,
here's our sub-game.
Here's our green sub-game.
Here's the node it starts from.
Here are all the nodes that are
successors of that node:
these are the children,
and these are the
grandchildren.
If you have this grandparent
node you have to have all of his
children, and all of his
grandchildren.
So it comprises all the
successors of that node.
And finally--this is
important--it does not break up
any information sets.
So a sub-game,
informally, it's just a game
within the game.
But slightly more formally,
I can't put one node that's
part of an information set into
this sub-game unless I'm going
to put all the nodes that are
part of that information set
into the sub-game.
Let's have a look at some
examples.
We've got one example up there,
the entry game looked something
like this.
So what are the sub-games here,
no secrets here,
this is a sub-game.
There's actually another
sub-game, can anyone see what
the other sub-game is?
The whole game is a sub-game.
The whole game is itself a
sub-game, somewhat trivially.
So this particular game,
which is the schematic of the
entry game, it has actually two
sub-games but only one proper
sub-game.
Here's a more complicated
example.
This is actually going to be
quite a complicated example just
to make life interesting.
So 1 is going to move,
then 2 is going to move,
and then 1 is going to move
again.
This is all one big information
set for Player 1.
And 1 is going to move like
this.
So again, without payoffs,
this is a little tree and the
key point here is this is an
information set.
Let's look-- let's stare--at
this tree a second and figure
out what are and aren't
sub-games.
So first of all,
this was a sub-game and this
was a sub-game.
What about this thing here?
Is that a sub-game?
It's not a sub-game.
What rule does it break?
It's breaking up an information
set, so that's no good because
of rule three.
What about this thing?
That doesn't break up an
information set.
I've got the whole information
set in there.
Is that any good?
No that's no good because it
doesn't start from a singleton
node, so that's no good it
violates 1.
If we do this,
we look at this piece.
That piece there,
that's also no good.
Why is that no good?
Again it breaks up an
information set,
so this is no good again
because of rule 3.
So you can practice at home
drawing trees and trying to
identify what are and what are
not sub-games.
So with the definition of a
sub-game now formal--it's
basically just formalizing
something we've talked about
before which is the idea of a
game within the game--I want to
introduce our new--what's going
to be our new solution concept.
And this is going to be the
solution concept we're going to
use essentially almost until the
final.
Definition, so just remember
what our task is.
Our task is to come up with a
solution concept that picks up
the idea from the first half of
the semester,
namely Nash equilibrium,
but does so in a way that
respects what we've learned in
the second half of the semester,
namely that games have
sequential elements and people
move by backward induction.
So, in particular,
what we want to rule out are
those Nash equilibria that
instruct players down the tree
to play in sub-games according
to strategies that are not Nash
equilibria.
Say it again,
we want to rule out those Nash
equilibria that instruct people
way down the tree to play
according to something which is
not a Nash equilibrium.
We want our new notion to say:
wherever you find yourself in a
tree, play Nash equilibrium and
that's exactly what the
definition's going to say.
So a Nash equilibrium,
S1*, S2* all the way up to SM*
is a sub-game perfect
equilibrium--so that's a
SPE--it's a sub-game perfect
equilibrium if it induces a Nash
equilibrium in every sub-game of
the game.
So to be a sub-game perfect
equilibrium, it has to itself be
a Nash equilibrium of course,
but it also has to instruct
players to play a Nash
equilibrium in every sub-game.
Let's take that immediately
back to our examples.
In this example,
we know that this is a
sub-game.
We know that,
in this sub-game,
there is only one Nash
equilibrium;
and that Nash equilibrium
involves Player 2 choosing down
and Player 3 choosing right.
So we know that Player 2 is
going to choose down according
to that equilibrium,
and Player 3 is going to choose
right according to that
equilibrium.
So if we now have to look for
an equilibrium of the whole
game--let's go back to Player
1's choice--Player 1 if they
choose A will get 1,
if they chose B then they know
that this Nash equilibrium will
be played so they'll get 2.
They prefer 2 to 1,
so the sub-game perfect
equilibrium here is Player 1
chooses B, Player 2 chooses
down, and Player 3 chooses
right.
This is an equilibrium of the
game and it induces an
equilibrium in the sub-game.
So in that example,
the sub-game perfect
equilibrium is found by first of
all looking in the sub-game;
find the equilibrium in the
sub-game;
and then go back and look at
the equilibrium in the whole
game.
The equilibrium that we end up
with, it is a Nash equilibrium
in the whole game,
but more importantly,
it induces a Nash equilibrium
in the sub-game.
Let's just go back to our other
example then I'll stop.
So our other example was here.
Here was our other example.
And we claimed,
hang on everybody,
we claimed that the good
equilibrium here,
the one we believed in was
(Down, down, right).
Where are the sub-games in this
game?
tree?
Anybody?
So I claim there's only one
real sub-game here and that's
this piece.
This is a sub-game.
What's the Nash equilibrium of
this somewhat trivial sub-game?
The Nash equilibrium of this
somewhat trivial sub-game is
that Player 1 must choose down.
So for a Nash equilibrium to be
a sub-game perfect
equilibrium--here are three Nash
equilibria: one,
two, three.
For this Nash equilibria to be
a sub-game perfect equilibrium,
it's got to instruct Player 1
to choose down in the trivial
sub-game and here it is.
This is our sub-game perfect
equilibrium in this game.
Now I know today was a lot of
formal stuff,
a lot of new ideas,
and when we come back on Monday
we'll first of all give you a
game that refreshes these ideas
and then we'll go straight to
applications.
So trust me:
there will be applications.
It will be useful.
See you on Monday.
There's a homework to come in,
there's another on the web
going out.